[Music]
when we're having a bad day memes are
always there to make us laugh we have to
admit that we all love to make fun of
these pictures even if we relate to them
a little too much but not everyone likes
these memes as much as we do some of the
people we see in these pictures don't
enjoy being an internet sensation
fortunately one of them got over it and
decided to make the best out of this bad
situation if you want to see what bad
luck Brian is doing now
make sure to watch this video if this is
your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up sit back
as we share 10 people who hate their
celebrity meme status scumbag Steve you
have probably seen this mean before a
kid with a sideways fitted cap in a fur
coat was standing in a hallway
his attitude inspired many jokes
involving high school douchebag
stereotypes some of the jokes included
hey can I borrow everything and grandpa
gets surgery steals pain meds but do you
know who this guy really is his name is
Blake Boston and he wanted to be a
rapper as you can see in this picture he
even admitted that he was a douchebag in
high school but not a thief or a person
with poor judgment like scumbag Steve at
the time he didn't even know what a meme
was until his friend showed him the
picture but Blake didn't like the fame
people couldn't separate the meme from
the real guy in the picture they knew
his name his Facebook profile and his
phone number they started calling him
and his family at all hours of the night
these strangers insulted him as if he
was really like scumbag Steve and even
threatened him and his family it seems
like a simple joke turned into something
no one should be laughing at but no
matter what Blake Boston still dreams of
becoming a rapper he believed that
artists should keep doing what they love
whether they suck or not really hi guy
if we ever become famous we would like
to be known as a great actor a talented
singer or an activist who wants to
change the world the last thing we want
is for everyone to see what we look like
the night we made one big mistake this
is what happened to the really high guy
also known as stoner Stan Lee the night
he smoked illicit substances since 2011
he has been seen with his red face and
strange gesture accompanied by the text
being
ten is not always pretty he became part
of many jokes including movie night two
hours spent watching DVD menu and guys I
just realized the kitchen as a place and
we have to admit we all laugh when we
saw one of these means stoner Stanley
was later identified as a British guy
named Conor Sinclair and that's all we
know about him he currently leads a
normal life and will always be known as
the meme of a guy under the influence we
hope that his future boss hasn't seen
this mean if he one day has an interview
for a new job this is one mistake that
he's going to regret forever friend zone
Johnny when the internet saw this
picture they all thought that the poor
Johnny was being friend-zoned he came to
this girl's house at midnight with
flowers in the box of chocolate to wish
her happy birthday the girl named Liz
took a picture and posted it on Facebook
saying that she was blessed to have such
a great friend what if the joke's on the
mean was planned for weeks humiliated
for a lifetime and that is exactly what
happened to Johnny solace his life
hasn't been the same since he became an
internet sensation when he was walking
in the hallway people were screaming his
name some of them even wanted to take a
picture with the famous friend zone
Johnny
and the humiliation didn't even stop
when he came back home his parents knew
about it and constantly laughed at him
they even told him to make t-shirts
solace later surprised people by
changing his facebook status to show
that he was married to Liz he later
admitted that this joke was her idea but
it was still a good way to make fun of
those who were laughing at him after so
many years he finally accepted what was
happening to him he had to admit that
Internet users were really creative and
had the best insults suburban mom we all
know about the suburban mom stereotype
and this woman was unlucky enough to
become their mascot many people related
to jokes like says video games will rot
your brain play farmville for six hours
as we would have thought the suburban
mom and didn't appreciate the means the
real name of this woman is curly
Phillips and she is a romance novelist
there was a lot of drama in her life too
because she didn't give the permission
to any kid to make this kind of joke
about her when she found out about the
meme she was horrified furious and hurt
she told her fans that she didn't want
anyone to
that she is like the woman in the
picture after all she let her kids watch
r-rated movies even though other parents
would be frustrated with her for that
Internet users took the time to explain
the joke and tell her that it wasn't
really at her expense
Carly said that she learned a lot in the
process she wrote that she believes she
is rational and reasonable but she just
wanted to mentally and psychologically
let it go
the writer still had to admit to her new
fans that she was infamous because of a
meme but it is what it is it didn't
represent her or her views hipster
barista we all met a hipster barista at
a cafe so we know what this meme is
about some of the funniest jokes include
a 120 thousand dollar art degree draws
face and latte foam and puts coffee deal
on Groupon rolls eyes when you actually
use it however one person is not
laughing right now Dustin Matson who
works at octane coffee when the barista
found out about this meme he
sarcastically tweeted that it was
representative of what he does to feed
his family he later said that it was
discouraging and disappointing that we
gave so much exposure to this kind of
mean Dustin explained that people love
farm-to-table food and craft beer but
have no respect for the specialty coffee
world but no matter what he won't let
this meme stop him he said that it made
him want to work harder at his job and
bring more exposure to the barista
profession he wished people could know
more about his work in the cafe so
they'll realize that it doesn't match up
with most of the jokes made against the
infamous hipster barista after all this
meme had positive consequences now
that's a great reason to buy a copy her
Maggard if you've never seen the are
Maggard meaning you have probably been
living under a rock some of the jokes
include I got 99 problems and a booking
one and I like your status on Facebook
but what is so funny about this is the
way these jokes are pronounced Maggie
golden burger was really surprised when
she realized that a picture of her 11
years old went viral she was certainly
not ready to become a celebrity
Maggie thought it was weird to see all
these pictures of her online but what
annoyed her the most was that her
friends never got over it
they loved revealing her online identity
every time they met a stranger they just
looked at all the versions of this meme
for 30 minutes during this time golden
burger just had to fake laugh as if she
never saw those pictures
for she couldn't believe it was her 15
minutes of fame the young woman just
hoped it would have come in another form
but she was not the only one who didn't
think this was funny
RL Stein the writer of the books was
asked many times for his thoughts on
armor gird he was worried that the meme
was mocking his readers and we
understand how these two people felt no
one would like more than 5 million
people to see an ugly picture of them
posted online college freshmen if you
ever went to college you know the
college freshmen this young student was
known for jokes like a drunk at a party
talks about it for a week and buys all
recommended textbooks this whole story
just started when brick and Christie had
a phone interview he thought it was the
end of the story until he was asked to
pose for a few snapshots this freshman
student didn't like that he had to be a
part of this photo shoot while everyone
was outside and looking at him
it wasn't a good way not to be noticed
during his first semester Griffin
certainly wasn't ready for what was
coming next becoming an internet
sensation he said that at first it
wasn't a big deal until people started
coming up to him it was really awkward
the freshmen also said that 90% of these
memes didn't apply to him but even
though he clearly didn't enjoy being
famous
he had one bad idea he posed for another
photograph years later and became a
double meme star he is now both the
college freshman and the successful
college senior at least we are happy to
see that he was doing well in college me
makers just made fun of him with this
joke goes to college doesn't move for
three years
stop girl we all know this kind of
feeling when we don't want to be filmed
but don't want to look rude either the
stop girls emotion was so specific but
also so universal and we have to admit
that she looks so cute doing it but some
people wanted to make it funnier and
erased her teeth from the Jeff anyway
this young woman was melding stop and
this is still what she wanted when she
saw the meme online she just wish
everyone would stop talking about her
Sarah was attending the University of
Dakota at the time she went to a game
but she never thought she would leave as
a meme she looked at the Jif online
every once in a while and couldn't
believe that it was so popular she had
been seen more than a million
everyone wondered who she was some fell
in love with her and watched the [ __ ] for
two hours straight and a few people even
said they wanted to marry her
if this wasn't enough her friend also
asked her to meet his son and have
dinner because he thought she's so cool
even though that kind of attention was
positive that was not what Sarah wanted
couldn't they just stop attractive
convict if we ever end up behind bars we
wish no one would ever know about that
unfortunately this convict was so
beautiful that she became a meme and
everyone knew about her we all laughed
when she saw jokes like can I have her
cell number and steals your heart and
your wallet however Megan Simmons only
saw this as a humiliating experience the
whole world knew that she was arrested
for reckless driving and slept with a
year probation but the popularity of her
mugshot was what inspired her to be
extra careful especially when her
children were concerned they didn't know
about it and she wanted to make sure no
one would recognize her Megan didn't
like the attention she got people
stopped her messaged her and said crazy
things some people wanted to visit her
pay her bills and even marry her that's
certainly not what she was looking for
when she got arrested
well what surprised us was when she
talked about what she really thought of
this picture she didn't think the photo
did her justice
there were other ones she would prefer
it is crazy to hear that when we know
that so many people fell in love with
this picture bad luck Brian one of our
favorite memes is bad luck Brian the
awkward teenager we can't help but laugh
when we see jokes like parents get
divorced
nobody wants custody and dating a blind
girl says she wants to start seeing
other people but even though this
student was not named Brian he was
really unlucky to become a meme no one
knew how to react when their picture was
mocked by millions of strangers at his
real job Kyle Craven didn't want to be
bad luck Brian he worked hard to be
known as Kyle and not as an awkward high
school student no one likes but whenever
he went on reddit he came across the
other version of himself his parents
wanted to take it down but Kyle had to
explain that the internet didn't work
like that
so he decided that he was going to make
the best out of this situation instead
Craven appeared in conferences sold
t-shirts and took pictures with
thousands of fans
he was even asked to let people use his
pictures for advertisements all around
the world
Kile estimated that he made between
15,000 and 20,000 off of bad luck Brian
in three years now that we know about
that we just wish we would become a
famous mean - and that's it for ten
people who hate their celebrity meme
status if one of your pictures was used
as a meme what do you think it would say
don't forget to tell us in the comment
section down below we love to hear from
you make sure you like this video if one
of these pictures made you smile and if
you want to learn more about memes just
watch the real story behind ten popular
internet memes thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]